[Música]
discutieron en persona por primera vez
como presidentes los puntos clave de sus
relaciones bilaterales el presidente
chino advirtió a su homólogo
estadounidense que Taiwán es una línea
roja que Washington no debe atreverse a
cruzar
bolodimirse lens que visitó la ciudad de
jerson recuperada por las autoridades
ucranianas tras La retirada de las
tropas de Moscú el secretario general de
la otan defendió que la retoma de gerson
demuestra la importancia del apoyo
militar a kiev
en Irán se cumplen dos meses de la
llegada de maxamen y al hospital con
muerte cerebral bajo la custodia de la
policía de la moral el país se ha
transformado tras dos meses de protestas
y de represión Mortal ante los niveles
de violencia del régimen la Unión
Europea ha emitido nuevas sanciones
contra Teherán Tenemos reporte
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Frank 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
empezamos esta edición en Bali Indonesia
porque en la víspera de la Cumbre del
g20 el presidente chino y el
estadounidense Joe biden discutieron los
puntos clave de sus relaciones
bilaterales fue el primer encuentro en
persona entre los dos hombres desde que
ambos son jefes de sus respectivos
estados coincidieron en el rechazo a
todo uso de armas nucleares en Ucrania
por otro lado sí advirtió a vaiden que
Taiwán es la primera línea roja que
Washington no debe cruzar y que Las
Guerras comerciales no interesan a nadie
Luis Muñoz nos trae un repaso de los
puntos cruciales de la relación entre
ambas potencias
evitar que la competencia se convierta
en el conflicto más temido fue la
premisa del primer cara a cara del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
su homólogo chino chilling Pink
creo que el mundo Espera que China y
Estados Unidos desempeña en papeles
clave y aborden los desafíos globales
desde el cambio climático hasta la
alimentación y la seguridad
la situación actual que enfrenta la
relación entre China y Estados Unidos es
una preocupación para todos nosotros
las relaciones entre ambos países están
en uno de sus peores momentos en décadas
por lo que los mandatarios hablaron
durante cerca de tres horas entre los
puntos principales estuvo Taiwán
territorio que Beijing considera una
provincia Rebelde y que ha prometido
reunificar así sea por la fuerza la isla
goza del apoyo económico y militar de
Washington
aviso a byden de que no cruce lo que
para china es una línea roja este
respondió
[Música]
yo creo que haya un inminente intento de
China de invadir Taiwán
también está la situación en la región
de Asia Pacífico Estados Unidos promete
reforzar su posición en la región si
china no actúa para contener los
programas armamentísticos norcoreanos
mientras que china no esconde su
molestia por la alianza aucus que dotará
de una flota de submarinosa propulsión
nuclear a Australia otro punto de
conflicto es la lucha comercial desde
Estados Unidos piden a sus empresas
reducir su dependencia de China mientras
que desde Beijing protestan por las
restricciones al acceso de productos
tecnológicos la guerra en Ucrania contó
con un punto de consenso
discutimos la agresión de Rusia a
Ucrania y compartimos la misma visión de
que el uso de armas nucleares es
totalmente inaceptable
los dos mandatarios llegan reforzados en
sus países vaiden tras retener el senado
en las elecciones de medio término y
shein Pink tras ser elegido en el
congreso del partido comunista
legitimidad con la que deberán decidir
si reconducir sus relaciones o seguir
por el camino de una peligrosa escalada
vamos ahora con información relativa a
la guerra en Ucrania porque el
presidente fue lodimerselli visitó la
ciudad de gerson retomada por las tropas
ucranianas tras La retirada
acusó al ejército de Moscú de cometer
crímenes de guerra Durante los meses que
ocuparon la zona y opinó que el
repliegue ruso de gerson El mayor desde
La retirada rusa de la región de kiev
representa el principio del fin de la
guerra por otro lado el secretario
general de la otan defendió que La
retirada rusa de la urbe evidencia la
importancia del apoyo militar a kiev los
detalles en el informe de Alba Santana
con la bandera ucraniana ondeando de
nuevo el presidente bolodimir zelenski
llegó para celebrar lo que ha sido una
de las mayores victorias de Ucrania en
la guerra hasta el momento la retoma de
gerson
capital regional que los rusos habían
ocupado desde el 2 de marzo pocos días
después del inicio del conflicto
[Aplausos]
Este es el principio del fin de la
guerra porque ya ven nuestro fuerte
ejército estamos avanzando paso a paso
por nuestro país por los territorios
temporalmente ocupados por supuesto es
una pena que el camino sea largo y
difícil
el 11 de noviembre Celeste anunció La
retirada de las tropas rusas y que
gerson volvía a estar bajo el control
ucraniano un logro que se debe en gran
parte a la ayuda proporcionada por la
otan y los aliados occidentales de kiev
que le han suministrado artillería y
misiles de alta precisión y que todo el
mundo celebró en persona no obstante las
autoridades ucranianas han pedido
precaución y han dicho que todavía no es
seguro volver a la ciudad ya que los
rusos podrían volver a atacar y la zona
está plagada de minas
el precio de esta guerra es muy alto
muchas personas resultaron heridas y
muchas murieron creemos que nuestro
ejército rodeó al enemigo y los rusos
estaban en gran peligro hubo una lucha
feroz y este es el resultado Hoy estamos
en gerson
Y es que esta guerra ha dejado a gerson
en ruinas con necesidad de ayuda
humanitaria y bombardeos que aún se
escuchan Rusia asegura no haber perdido
ni uno de sus 30.000 soldados y que La
retirada solo es parte de una
reorganización estratégica tras la
visita de celenski El kremlin dijo que
jerson sigue siendo rusa ahora el río
nieper actúa como frontera entre los dos
bandos de la guerra
vamos ahora a Irán porque hoy se cumplen
dos meses desde que Martha minid llegó
con muerte cerebral al hospital bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral las
protestas desatadas por la muerte de la
joven kurdo iraní y la mortal represión
ejercida por las autoridades han
transformado la sociedad de la República
islámica nos lo cuenta nuestra
corresponsal enteran Catalina Gómez
Ángel
han pasado dos meses desde quemaxa mini
fue detenida por la policía la moral y
llevada luego con muerte cerebral a un
hospital no muy lejos de aquí e Irán es
un país totalmente
diferente muy con una mayor indignación
de la población de la que había entonces
pero también con una mayor división
entre aquellos que apoyan al sistema de
la República islámica y aquellos
especialmente liderados por los jóvenes
y por las mujeres que piden un cambio en
el sistema y es que esos miles de
jóvenes que se movilizaron en un
comienzo bajo ese eslogan de mujer vida
y Libertad sansem de guías allí
rápidamente cambiaron su eslogan a
muerte al dictador pidiendo por mayores
cambios en la república islámica Y eso
no solamente en las grandes ciudades
sino también en pequeñas poblaciones de
muchas regiones del país y se hicieron
más fuertes en dos grandes provincias
fronterizas en el sistema lucha están en
el sur y en el kurdistán iraní De dónde
es proveniente
giras protestas continúan y la represión
es cada vez mayor el gobierno de la
República islámica acusa a los grupos
opositores kurdos de liderar estas
protestas y hoy atacaba bases de estos
grupos en el curdir aquí como lo había
hecho en el pasado pero las protestas
Aunque ya no son tan extendidas en la
calle debido a la represión de las
autoridades que han capturado al menos
15.000 personas Si siguen existiendo de
manera simbólica y especialmente en las
universidades donde los jóvenes piden la
liberación de esos presos especialmente
a los estudiantes y ponen como línea
roja las condenas apenas de muerte Ellos
dicen que si esto sucede ya habrían ya
será el fin para la República islámica
pero ayer ya se conoció que la primera
persona había sido condenada a muerte no
se conoció su nombre dicen que quemó un
edificio gubernamental Pero hay otras
personas que estarían esperando la misma
condena para los próximos tres días
están convocadas nuevas prote y paros
nacionales y a la espera de saber cómo
reacciona la población
precisamente a raíz del aumento de la
represión en Irán la Casa Blanca expresó
su preocupación y violan bienvenida a
las nuevas sanciones que Reino Unido y
la Unión Europea dispusieron hoy contra
Teherán tal y como nos mencionaba en
nuestra corresponsal la fuerza pública
iraní ha detenido acerca de 15.000
personas y ha matado a más de 300 según
la ong Irán Human Rights ante este nivel
de violencia Bruselas congeló los
activos y prohibió la entrada a
territorio comunitario al ministro del
interior de Irán azmadbaida y a otras 28
personalidades de las fuerzas armadas y
de la unidad de la policía de la moral
que arrestó a masaminev las sanciones
también afectan a tres entidades que
trabajan para el gobierno en el bloqueo
de las comunicaciones y que graban y
emiten Confesiones forzadas de los
detenidos escuchemos a la ministra de
relaciones exteriores de Alemania
adoptaremos otro paquete de sanciones
para enviar un mensaje claro a quienes
creen que pueden reprimir intimidar y
matar a su propio pueblo sin
consecuencias no pueden hacer eso esto
tiene consecuencias y el mundo Europa
está mirando
las nuevas sanciones se dirigirán en
particular al círculo interno de poder
de la guardia Revolucionaria y las
estructuras que los financian seguimos
trabajando para poner en marcha más
medidas
y en otras noticias en Turquía las
autoridades investigan el atentado bomba
de ayer que causó seis muertos y 81
heridos en Estambul la fuerza pública ha
detenido a 47 personas incluida la
principal sospechosa a esta hora ningún
grupo a reivindicado el ataque pero El
Ejecutivo de recepta Jeep erdogan culpa
a las milicias kurdas de Siria esto sin
embargo niegan cualquier implicación en
los hechos nos informa Alba Santana
la principal sospechosa en manos de las
autoridades una mujer kurdo sería es
señalada de ser presuntamente la autora
del atentado que se saldó con varios
muertos y decenas de heridos en Estambul
la persona que llevó a cabo el incidente
la que dejó la bomba ha sido detenida
por la policía de Estambul Turquía las
milicias kurdas de jepg en covani una
ciudad del norte de Siria que es
objetivo militar de los turcos no
obstante el líder kurdo de la región más
de un abdi ha negado cualquier
implicación
afirmamos que nuestras fuerzas no tienen
nada que ver con el atentado de Estambul
y rechazamos las acusaciones que acusan
a nuestras fuerzas de ello expresamos
nuestras más sinceras condolencias a las
familias y al pueblo Turco y deseamos
una pronta recuperación a los heridos Y
es que Turquía sostiene que las milicias
kurdas de Siria son un grupo terrorista
con vínculos con el partido de los
trabajadores de kurdistán enemigo del
ejecutivo Turco algo que ha tensado
incluso sus relaciones con Estados
Unidos
rechazamos las condolencias de la
embajada estadounidense no las aceptamos
nuestra Alianza con este estado que
envía dinero de su propio senado para
estos grupos fomentando los grupos de
Cobán y que quieran perturbar la paz de
Turquía está en una situación
controvertida
a pesar de que la autoría del crimen
Todavía no se ha esclarecido el atentado
ha causado conmoción en el país y miedo
a que este tipo de ate se conviertan en
algo habitual de Cara a las elecciones
de junio de 2023 en las que receta Jeep
erdogan podría perder por primera vez
tras dos décadas en el poder
y cerramos con deportes la selección de
fútbol de Francia campeona del último
mundial inició hoy su concentración de
Cara a Qatar 2022 con más lesionados y
nombres nuevos en este primer
entrenamiento estuvo la periodista de
Franz 24 Natalia Ruiz giraldo quien
también asistió a la conferencia de
prensa del equipo veamos
primer entrenamiento del libro aquí en
oklahonda en alas afueras de París una
convocatoria que tuvo dos cambios
importantes esta mañana Por una parte la
baja depende del defensa que finalmente
no logró estar a tope para este mundial
debido a su lesión en el talón de
Aquiles Así que ha sido cambiado por una
novato esta vez se trata de jugadores
del Mónaco acceder que así mientras que
hubo también una convocatoria para un
número un jugador 26 17
Para ocupar ese lugar y precisamente una
conferencia de prensa y se le preguntó
si había o no tiempo de preparación para
este mundial Y eso nos dijo si lo hay
uno
no la hay si lo ven muchos jugadores
tuvieron partido ayer y hoy y mañana
servirán sobre todo de recuperación
viajamos el miércoles y tendremos como
en un club menos de una semana desde el
jueves para preparar el partido del
martes
[Música]
el jueves será Entonces el primer
entrenamiento de los franceses en
tierras catarillas esperan ya aparece
entonces tener las piernas un poquito
más frescas y ya recuperarse también
físicamente de uno que otro golpe y
comenzar entonces con brío esa defensa
del título mundial será el próximo
martes 22 de noviembre ante Australia
así llegamos al final de esta edición
sigan con nosotros en Francia 24 y Frank
34.com
[Música]